I have been doing content writing for
about 5 years now and trust me it's not
an easy as it looks as a Content writer
there are lot of challenges from start
to finish you have got to really know
who you are writing for and make sure
your content is right for them your
writing should be short clear and in
good order and don't forget to keep your
writing style friendly and the same
throughout but it's not just about
writing as a Content writer you also
need to make sure your content works
well on search engines check and fix
mistakes a lot and keeps it unique and
you have got to listen to what the
client says to make it better it's
tiring making great content that really
helps client takes a lot of time
sometimes you run out of time and the
quality of your work might not be as
good making you less productive but here
is the good news today I am sharing a
quick trick for Content writers that
saves times boost creativity and
productivity and keeps the quality
topnotch I am introducing top five EI
tools for Content writing in 2024 but
before we begin if you are an aspiring
content writer and want to learn the
best content writing techniques in the
industry to a your digital marketing
career then you are at the right place
introducing bir postgraduate program in
digital marketing which will be your all
over companion with this program you
will not only ace in content writing but
also keyword research search engine
optimization behavioral marketing
campaign management social media
marketing and much more with these
technical expertise you will also gain
complete Hands-On learning with the
tools like Google Keyword Planner chat
GPT Google ads Google analytics and
there are more than 30 tools in the list
reserve your seats first and R now from
the link in the description box and pin
comment before we move ahead with top
five AI tools for Content writing
consider subscribing to Simply learn and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from us so let's begin with top
five AI tools for Content writing on
number five on the list we have is wrer
wrer is an AI powered sentence
completion tool that enables you to
create high quality original content
within minutes it smart features in
includes language autod detection so you
can create content in multiple languages
its eii is powered by gpt3 that will
help you to create content that compete
with professionals with this smart
editor you can write it in clear tones
that will immediately connect with your
target audience right here exists in
both free and paid versions you can use
up to 10,000 tokens in free version
while the paid version starts from $19
per
month just go to wrer doio log to your
account find the settings where you need
to choose whether you are a single
writer or you work with a team or what
is the main motive of yours to uh use
this tool once you are done you can see
this screen so this editor provides the
feature of either sentence completion or
you can also create the complete data or
the article or anything whatever you
want to try so right now let's as we are
already talking about the content
writing let's take a small introduction
of what is content writing with using
the
[Music]
writer. let's start by knowing what is
content writing and once you click on
the completion you'll get the small
intro about content
writing yeah there you go so we have got
a small introduction about what is
content writing like this you can create
whatever ad copies or you you need to
create an article or blogs or whatever
kind of content you want and from the
right side you can see there are certain
settings where you can choose the
languages a language for your writing it
may UK English or us English then
grammarly you can use it the don't can
be formal or informal and the creativity
and everything the length of the content
moving to number four on the list which
is copy. a copy. a stands out as a
versatile tool that enables content
teams to boost their output by 10 times
without compromising quality with an
array of 90 plus tools and templates it
guides user through the creation of
diverse content including blog post
landing pages payer click PPC ad copy
social media post and much more copy. a
is available in both free and paid
versions you can create content for free
up to 2,000 words per month
however with the paid versions there is
no word limit and it will come at $149
per month so just log to copy. a web app
and where you'll get an option of chat
so we are already here I have logged in
and I have got certain again I have got
certain uh options to choose whether I'm
a just I'm working as a single content
writer or just choose whatever option is
for you and just click on the chat so
here we can get all the requirements uh
it is again the generated kind of stuff
which we are getting with the
copy. so let's take an example to write
a copy for a social media post for
perfume r so here I'll
find write a social media post for
a for a
Pur brand
name super
profs
let's
see let's try if we can get another more
options from
this let
provide two other
versions and let me tell you this what
I'm using is completely free of cost so
yeah you got a number of versions here
and from this even if you have certain
points to be included you can just make
those changes in this um chat section
and you can get the change version of
above
versions the next tool on the list is WR
Sonic right Sonic is gaining popularity
in the list of AI tools from past few
months a perfect place to create long
form and short form content so get
content ready write the best blog post
SEO descriptions product descriptions or
any web content needed with right Sonic
it includes multiple features like it
carry out plagarism checks maintain
brand voice that makes it One-Stop
solution for Content writers right Sonic
is available in both free and paid plans
free plan includes 10,000 words per
month however the paid version starts
from $113 and go as high as1 500 per
month log to the right Sonic account
using your Google or any email ID once
you log to WR Sonic you'll get the
number of things like library history
you get number of other uh right Sonic
apps like audio Sonic and Jack Sonic and
you can create content using those also
they also provide uh image generations
and text to
speech uh even the generative a using
chap on you can write an article or
create your own document let's try to
use the chatboard or the chat Sonic and
write
s
create an article on what is content
right let's
see B is working to create an article on
what is content
writing you you can see that within few
seconds we got a article of very good
words
length and what I can see from this was
it looks completely SEO optimized with
the keyword content writing and it
covers almost all the possibilities of
content writing like purpose of content
writing we get the types of content
writing like blog writing website
content we are getting social media
content copy writing technical writing
and definitely they are not just
providing about the content writing but
skills required to become a Content
writer or skills required for Content
writing the next tool or number two in
the list is writer writer the another
widely used content writing platform
famous for its short form content
features if you are looking to create
content for social media product
descriptions emails for marketing and
sales SEO meta title website copies and
much more then yes writer is your
perfect companion writer is available in
free and paid versions free version
provides 10,000 words per month while
paid version starts from $19 per month
to use this web app you just need to log
to the writer account and you will get
option to create a copy to create an
image and to create a chat so let's use
a
chat so let's try to create content for
the very first perose we have
used write the
homepage content for the perfume
brand also writer also provides the
facility to add or edit already created
document you can do it from the new
document feature here so here we can see
we got a very good length of content
which shows and uh describes in detail
about a perfume brand you can
additionally add any of your points to
cover if anything is missing or if it is
required by a client or any changes any
addition any
donation here I'm using the free version
of Writer
app at number one we have Chad GPT Chad
GPT can assist in content creation by
generating ideas expanding drafts
providing editing suggestions answering
queries aiding in creative writing
suggesting language enhancement and
offering basic translation services it
is available in free and paid versions
Chad gbt 3.5 is available for free
version whereas gbd4 is available in
paid
versions as we know chat gbt is a widely
used tool and I'm here using Char 3.5
which is completely the free version for
chat uh gp4 is the paid version as we
discussed earlier first we try to write
the Facebook ad copy for the BK
so
right Facebook
and
copy
for perfume
brand perfume Dr
super
super within few seconds we got almost
everything for a super perfumed brand
they are covering the website link
they're adding the hashtags and
everything
just completely add
optimized so here we wrap up top five AI
tools for Content writing covering the
best free tools used by content experts
do give it a try and let us know your
thoughts in the comment section below if
you find this video informative do like
it and share it with your friends stay
tuned with us to stay updated with the
latest industry Trends till we meet
again thanks for watching watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here